- [Narrator] This Great
Big Story was made possible
by Wells Fargo.
Established 1852.
Re-established 2018.
(intense metal music)
- [Narrator] Okay, so "Mad Max"
or Comic-Con in the desert?
Nope.
This is Winter Metal Mania Fest.
- Hey!
(growls)
- [Narrator] Just a bunch of
metalheads that want to prove
that Botswana can thrash
as good as the rest.
(growls)
And none go harder than these guys.
- [Man] Welcome!
(speaks in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The die-hard death metal band
formed back in 2008
and have worked their way to become
one of the country's leading acts.
(intense metal music)
- [Narrator] Botswana might
not be the first country
that comes to mind for this.
(intense guitar music)
Or this.
(intense metal music)
But the metal scene
here has some momentum.
- [Narrator] For nine years,
Overthrust has been
headlining their festival,
part of a lineup that now hosts
acts from all over Africa.
(audience cheers)
- [Man] This song is
called "Soul to Feed!"
(intense metal music)
- [Narrator] And for Vulture Thrust,
like any true metalhead,
it's about so much more than the music.